[Music]
and there you go RTX 490 unboxing hope
you guys enjoyed the
[Music]
video Welcome Back to hun box today we
are taking our first look at nvidia's
new GeForce 40 series with the current
Flagship model the GeForce RTX 49 and as
I'm sure many of you are aware it's a
chunk graphics card you're probably also
aware that it has a fairly disappointing
asking prices Nvidia did provide all the
pricing information in their keynote
four weeks ago now but if you haven't
heard the bad news pricing does start at
$1600 us so there's a lot to talk about
here but before we do let's quickly
touch on the specifications and then
take a look at the founders Edition
model and then of course we will get
into those blue bar graphs the RTX 490
is based on the a102 Silicon which
measures 68 .4 mm squ so it is 3%
smaller than that of g102 used by the
GeForce 380 and 390 series but of course
nvidia's moved from the Samsung 8N
process with ampere to tsmc's 4N process
for ad0 LEL and quite incredibly this
has seen the transistor count increase
by
170% from 28.3 billion to an insane
76.3 billion when compared to the RTX 3
90 TI there's 52% more streaming
multiprocessors Cuda cores tensor cores
RT cores and texture units the r count
has increased by 57% and the Boost clock
has been wound up by
35% that said the same 21 GBS per second
gddr 6X memory has been used and there's
still 24 GB of the stuff on a 384bit
wide memory bus and this results in the
same 1,8 gb/ second of memory bandwidth
and Nvidia is still using the PCI press
4.0 * 16
interface now Nvidia claims a total
Graphics power rating of 450 WS for the
RTX 490 and that's the same rating that
was given to the 390 TI though the
maximum GPU temperature has been
slightly downgraded from 93° to 90° the
minimum power supply requirement is 850
ws and as luck would have it that's what
I'll be using for all of my testing now
in terms of design the founders Edition
490 looks very similar to the 3090
though there are some fairly significant
changes the most notable of which is the
width on paper Nvidia claims a triple
slot form factor for both models which
is accurate but whereas the 3090 is 52
mm wide the 490 is 177% wider at 61 mm
though despite that rather large
increase both models weigh about the
same amount and at 2,190 G the 490 is
less than a percent heavier than the
3090 so that's surprising but what's not
surprising in is the absence of the NV
link connector which Nvidia has now
killed off and will instead just use the
PCI 4.0 bus the only other major change
here is the 16 pin power input which has
been upgraded to the PCI 5.0 spec
otherwise known as the super catchy 12
vpwr power connector a single pcie 5.0
connector can deliver up to 600 ws and
previously that would require four 8 Pin
power connectors however you won't need
a new pc 5 compliant power supply as RTX
490s do come with a 4 * 8 Pin to single
16 pin adapter similar to the time 38
pin to 16 pin model supplied with the
390 TI I should also note that it was
false the reported the 12 vpwr power
connector could only survive 30 Cycles
so 30 connects and disconnects but
that's not the case and connector
longevity will be similar to what we saw
with the8 pin connectors so that is to
say you're basically never going to wear
one out now apart from the increase in
cores the inclusion of fourth generation
tensor cores and third generation RT
cores the GeForce 40 series also
introduces dss3 a feature that at least
for now is exclusive to the GeForce 40
series now this new frame rate
multiplying technology is super exciting
stuff and I will only very briefly show
some results here but please note our
full analysis of dss3 will be available
a few days after this review goes live
DS S3 requires a significant amount of
test testing and Analysis Which is far
beyond the scope of a day one review so
please be patient as we work on that
content to provide a dedicated video
shortly now for testing all gpus have
been tested at the official clock
specification so no Factor overclocking
the CPU used was the ryzen 7 5800 X 3D
with 32 GB of dual rank dual Channel
ddr4 3200 C4 memory on the MSI MPG x570
s carbon Wi-Fi motherboard and in total
I've tested 13 games at 1440 and 4K so
let's get into the data starting with
Watchdog Legion at 1440p the RTX 490
doesn't look that impressive here sure
it's the fastest thing we've ever seen
but just a 9% boost over the 6950 XT is
hardly or inspiring we did see a more
substantial 22% uplift over the 3090 TI
but even so given today's GPU prices
that's not amazing all of that said the
issue is less with the RTX 490 here and
more with the ryzen 750 X3 3D which has
now become the primary system bottleneck
therefore when increasing the resolution
to 4K we get to see just how brutally
fast the RTX 490 really is we're now
looking at a monstrous 60% boost over
the 6950 XT and a 64% uplift from the
3090 TI that's incredible and we are now
getting a truly High refresh rate
experience at
4K it does appear though that we have a
lot more CPU Headroom in Rainbow 6
extraction at 4 1440p is here the RTX
490 was 59% faster than the RTX 390 TI
while it was also 71% faster than the
390 and 6950 XT again this is a
seriously impressive performance uplift
then jumping up to 4K didn't really
change too much this time as we weren't
CPU Limited at 1440p so the 490 was
again almost 60% faster than the 390 TI
though the margin to the 6950 XT did
grow and now we're looking at a 102%
it here for AMD so that's extremely
brutal to say the least now Far Cry 6 is
a better title for the radon brand and
at 1440p we pretty heavily CPU limited
so the 49 was only able to push ahead of
the 6950 XT by a 9% margin rendering 187
FPS though the 1% lows were boosted by
133% again jumping up to the 4K
resolution releases the RTX 490
resulting in incredible performance
gains averaging an
impressive 164 FP p s that's a 34%
uplift from the 6950 XT so not as big as
some of the gains we've seen but still
very much a commanding lead and the jump
up from the RTX 392 I was certainly more
sizable as here we're looking at a 50%
boost and almost 60% over the standard
390 Assassin's Creed valella is another
title that works well with radon gpus
and the excellent support for resizable
bar certainly helps the red team as a
result at 1440p the RTX 490 was 27 7%
faster than the 6950 XT which is a
decent gain but certainly far less
impressive than most of the margins
we've seen so far it was also just a 37%
improvement from the 390 TI and not the
typical 60% margin seen at 4K speaking
of which at 4K the 490 rended 116 FPS on
average making it 33% faster than the
6950 XT and 38% faster than the 390 TI
and again while certainly solid margins
these results are a little bit
disappointing given what we've SE so far
and we're certainly not CPU Limited at
4K hunt Showdown fans after the ultimate
in performance will love what the RTX
4090 has to offer serving up over 300
FPS at 440p with 1% lows of over 260 FPS
that's a massive 62% increase from the
390 TI 67% from the standard 390 and a
71% increase over AMD 6950 XT so the RTX
490 is again brutally fast even at 144
40p where we've often run into CPU
limitations with the 5800 X 3D
unexpectedly though the margins shrink
at 4K and now the 490 is 50% faster than
the 390ci and 62% faster than the 390 so
that's not at all what we were expecting
to find the margin to the 6950 XT though
remained much the same at 70% in any
case those are some pretty big margins
and it means that those wanting to play
hunt showdown at 4K and still receive a
high refresh rate experience can do so
with the RTX
4090 the outer World saw a 55%
performance increase for the 490 over
the 390 tii at 1440p and a mega 71%
increase over the 6950 XT I'm not sure
you need 268 FPS in the outter worlds
but it's now possible using the highest
quality preset at 1440p the 4K results
are probably more impressive despite the
fact that the Gap to the 3092 has shrunk
slightly to 51% that's because we're now
able to receive a true High refresh rate
experience at 4K in this title when
using the RTX 490 whereas most other
gpus struggle to hit 100 FPS The Hitman
3 results at 40 40p are quite clearly
CPU limited and no surprises here we
often use this title for CPU testing as
it is very CPU demanding when compared
to the 390 TI we're looking at just a 7%
uplift so this will be a good
configuration for testing CPUs such as
zen4 and of course Intel's upcoming
rapto Lake series moving to for K
demonstrates very clearly just how CPU
limited the 1440p results were as here
the RTX 490 pulled ahead of the 390 TI
by a massive 60% margin while pulling a
similar margin on the 6950 XT again the
RTX 490 is brutally fast here this is
incredibly impressive stuff moving on to
Horizon Zero D we again find another
example of CPU bottlenecking at 1440p
and this time we're using the highest
quality visual preset so 212 FPS is the
limit of of the 5800 x3d when running
the new RTX 490 which is a 20% increase
from the 6950 XT and 31% from the 390 TI
but again we find that the 4K resolution
is required to better demonstrate the
power of the RTX 490 and here the new
gForce GPU was good for 157 FPS on
average so a 54% boost from the 390 TI
and 67% over the 6950
XT unfortunately I haven't had enough
time to upgrade our GPU data to f f122
so we'll have to stick with my recently
gathered F1 2021 numbers which are based
on the maximum quality preset with the
default level of rad tracing enabled
here the RTX 490 pumped out 245 FPS
making almost 60% faster than 39 tii and
76% faster than the 6950 XT so a mega
result here at
1440p jumping up to 4K extended the
margin over the 390 TI as here the 490
was seen to deliver 71% more frames and
an insane 104% more than the 6950 XT
though amd's weak RT performance will be
letting down the radio on GPU here still
incredible stuff even over nvidia's own
previous generation Flagship we know
that cyberpunk 277 is both a very CPU
and GPU demanding game but with the RTX
490 installed we're almost certainly CPU
bound at 1440p here the 490 was good for
145 FPS and average making it 33% faster
than the 6950 X1 36% faster than the 390
TI the margin seen at 4K aren't quite as
Extreme as I was expecting but still 51%
over the 390 TI is hardly anything to
scoff at especially given that the RTX
1490 pushed well past 60 FPS while all
other gpus fell short of that Target
next up we have Dying Light 2 and this
time the 490 was 51% faster than the
6950 XT at 1440p and a massive 68%
faster than the 390 ti so another
incredible generation uplift there and
we see that it's much the same story at
4K 49% faster than the 6950 XT and 58%
faster than the 3090 TI the second last
game tested is Halo infinite and here
we're looking at fairly typical gains at
1440p 52% faster than the RTX 390 TI and
60% faster than the 6950 XT then at 4K
those margins are extended now the 490
is 72% faster than the 390 TI which is
an incredible performance leap and then
we see it's also 86% faster than the
6950 XT which as I've said before is a
brutal margin over previous generation
flagships finally we have shut off the
Tomb Raider and for our zen4 CPU testing
we found that this game was GPU Limited
at 1080p with the RTX 390 TI moving to
the RTX 490 we see that this is no
longer going to be an issue as this
thing cranked out an insane
237 FPS at 1440p using the highest
quality Pres set that's a 55% boost over
the 6950 XT and a 59% increase over the
390 ti so more jawdropping results here
speaking of jawdropping results at 4K
the RTX 490 is an incredible 70% faster
than the RTX 390 TI and 84% faster than
the 6950 XT pumping out 160 FPS at 4K
pretty amazing stuff especially given
that previous generation models couldn't
even reach 100 FPS okay so here's a look
at the 13 game average which has been
calculated using the geom the RTX 490
pumped out 219 FPS making it on average
44% faster than the 6950 XT and 45%
faster than the 390 TI both of which are
huge margins but somewhat under
represented the 490 as the 5800 X 3D was
limiting performance here on multiple
occasions and it's pretty crazy to think
that one of the fastest gaming CPUs
available today can be a serious
bottleneck for the 490 at 1440p and in
many cases we were using the highest or
very high visual quality settings I feel
this is the point where technology such
as rate tracing become truly viable and
we'll look at that in a moment but
before we do here's the 4K data and on
average the RTX 490 was 59% faster than
the 390 TI and 71% faster than the 6950
XT those are some massive margins
especially given they represent the
average seen across the 13 games tested
just as impressive is the fact that the
4090 averaged 145 FPS at 4K this is
truly the first 4K GPU capable of
delivering a high refresh rate gaming
experience so very impressive stuff here
by
Nvidia now I haven't bothered looking at
the 1080p results for the 13 games
tested though I did gather all of that
data and the reason I didn't bother
looking at it was because we already had
a lot to go over with the 1440p and 4K
data and of course the 1080p results
were often very heavily CPU limited
still overall the 490 was 28% FAS than
the 390 TI at 1080p using the ryzen7
5800 x3d and 24% FAS than the 6950 XT so
it's still very impressive here and if
anything a great tool for testing CPU
performance okay time for a look at the
rracing and upscaling results and we'll
start with
f122 at 1440p the 490 was just 11%
faster than the 3090 TI and 24 % faster
than the 6950 XT when comparing standard
rasterization performance so the ultra
high quality preset but with rt effects
disabled then with rt plus dlss enabled
the 490 was just 177% faster than 390
tii or 29% faster than the 6950 XT which
was using FSR for upscaling then with
just RT enabled so no upscaling methods
enabled the 490 was a massive 78% FAS
than the 390 TI and 167% faster than the
6950 XT so while the 6950 XT was still
able to deliver playable performance
with more than 60 FPS at all times the
490 provided a true High refresh rate
experience the 490 also affords you the
ability to enjoy maximum visual quality
at 4K with rate tracing enabled
comparing the standard rization results
the 490 was 61% faster than the 390 TI
then a massive 86% faster with rt and
dlss enabled and a breathtaking 91% FAS
with just RT and no dlss going from 54
FPS with the 39 to 103 FPS for the 490
simply amazing and that's also more than
three times the performance you'll get
with the 6950 XT next we've got Watch
Dogs Legion and we'll start with the
1440p data which shows a fairly small
margin between the 6950 XT and RTX 490
due to a CPU bottleneck now this game
doesn't support FSR and therefore the
6950 XT lack upscaling support so I've
just tested two R tracing modes
comparing the 390 TI and 490 sees no
difference in performance using dlss
with rt enabled the dlss bottleneck
appears to be about 109 FPS in this
title interestingly the 490 doesn't even
require dlss here as it produced the
same performance with ultra quality rrac
effects enabled making it 33% faster
than 3090 TI and 91% faster than the
6950 XT as usual though we did get a
better picture of just just how powerful
the 490 is at 4K this time using dlss
with r tracing saw a 43% gain for the
490 over the 390 and then with upscaling
disabled the 490 was 68% faster and 155%
faster than the 6950
XT next we have Marvel's Guardians of
the Galaxy and at 1440p we find another
example where dlss does very little for
the already Mighty impressive RTX 490 as
a result when comparing the ray tracing
Ultra quality plus de test results
between the 390 tii and 490 the new Ada
love lace GPU was just 133% faster
however if we ditch the upscaling we see
that the 490 is now 47% faster of course
it's the 4K results where we see the
biggest margins and this time dlss is of
benefit for the 490 pushing it ahead of
the 390 TI by a 54% margin and then 131%
faster than the 6950 XT using FSR then
with no upscaling but with rt Ultra
enabled the 490 was 58% faster than the
390 TI and 88% faster than the 6950
XT now the rate tracing performance in
Dying Light to is quite brutal
especially without the aid of dlss for
example at 1440p the 39 is only good for
52 FPS on average though that
performance can be bumped up to 86 FPS
using dlss quality Mode still that means
using dlss with rt enabled the 490 was
98% faster than the 390 TI and in insane
117% faster without the aid of upscaling
the 4K data is just as impressive I'm
not exactly sure why but the 390 TI does
quite poorly using the rracing quality
preset In Dying Light 2 but with the RT
settings turned off so what should be
just standard rasterization performance
using direct X12 sees the 490 delivering
122% greater performance so again I'm
not sure why that is even with dlss
enabled the 490 was still 110% faster
and then 15% faster with the upscaling
disabled now the last game we're going
to look at R tracing and dlss
performance with is cyberp pun 2077 at
1440p the RTX 490 with rtfx disabled was
36% faster than the 390 TI and that
margin is again seen with rt Ultra Plus
dlss quality enabled but it does blow
out to a massive 69% margin when using
RT without dlss as here the 490 was
still good for 86 FPS then at 4K the RTX
490 R is the RTX 392 delivering 72%
greater performance with rt and dlss
enabled and then 80% with just ra
tracing enabled though we're only
looking at 45 FPS on average here lastly
here's a look at dlss 3 Performance and
please note we will have a detailed
analysis of this technology in a
dedicated video shortly Now 1440p using
the high quality preset the RTX 490 was
good for 145 FPS on average in cyp Punk
2077 making it around 35% faster than
both the 390 TI and 6950 XT however with
dlss 3 enabl Performance appears to have
been boosted by 90% to 276 FPS and with
limited testing the game did feel smooth
but of course I'm very keen to see what
Tim digs up in his detailed testing now
the real advantage of dss3 can be seen
with ultra quality rate tracing enabled
is here the 490 was good for 191 FPS and
average making almost 70% faster than
dlss 2 and of course the real Advantage
can be seen at 4K where the 490 pumped
out 113 FPS using dss3 in conjunction
with ultra RT effects a 43% boost over
dlss 2 incredible stuff and again with
my limited testing the game did look
good it felt very smooth but putting
these numbers into context will be Tim's
detailed analysis which again will be
available in a few days from now okay so
here's a look at total system power
consumption when playing Halo at 1440p
and as you can see the RTX 490 actually
isn't bad
in fact it's very good delivering 50%
more performance in the RTX 390 TI while
using less power now both the 49 and 390
TI are 450 W graphics cards so
technically they should consume about
the same amount of power but the reason
the 390 TI can be seen pushing total
system usage about 50 wats higher is
because there's no founded Edition model
of the 390 TI and instead we're using an
MSI card which uses above spec voltage
so although I have clocked it down to
the official Nvidia specification which
shaves a few % off in terms of
performance the higher voltage means
power consumption is still higher than
what it would be for a base model anyway
the point is the RTX 490 is a 450 W
product so power consumption isn't
anything we haven't seen before from
Flagship graphics cards here's a look at
just how power efficient the RTX 490 is
by locking the frame rate at 90 FPS we
can see how much power each GPU uses and
I'll be comparing the 490 with the 390
TI and 6950 XT at this locked frame rate
the 490 consumed just 215 watts and that
means for the same level of performance
the 390 TI required 93% more power and
the 6950 XT 40% more power so despite
all the talk of the 490 being just this
outrageous out ofcontrol Beast it's
actually extremely impressive when it
comes to power efficiency now when it
comes to cooling performance the founded
Edition RTX 490 peaked at 83° for the
hot spot after an hour of load in a 21°
room installed inside an ATX case with
the doors closed the average GPU
temperature peaked at 72° and the memory
temperature picked at 84° so all those
temperatures are very acceptable
especially given the low operating
volume with a fan speed of just, 1600
RPM the operating volume was just 42 DB
which is quieter than most high-end and
even mid-range graphics cards that I've
tested in the past and during this
testing the core clock speed held pretty
steady at 2730 MHz and of course the
memory ran at 21 gbits per second and
finally the GPU power draw averaged 415
wats now via overclocking I was able to
push the founders Edition CES up to
2,895 MHz so a fairly typical 6% boost
there and the memory hit 24 1/2 gbits
per second this increased the GPU power
to 470 wats on average which is a 133%
increase though the fan speed didn't
really increase but the Hotpot
temperature did climb to 86° so a 5%
increase there and the memory also
jumped up by
4° when it comes to performance figures
we're looking at a fairly mild 7% boost
in Hitman taking the RTX 490 from 182
fps to 194 FPS and it's a similar story
in Watchdog Legion where the overclocked
490 was 6% faster going from 141 fps to
150 FPS and we also saw a 6% boost in s
Punk 2077 so nothing crazy there but as
you'd expect from a product like the 49
it's pushed pretty hard out of the box
okay time for the cost per frame
analysis and I'll start with the 1440p
data using the suggested retail pricing
for each model based on the MSRP the 490
looks very good even when using the more
CPU limited 1440p data in terms of cost
per frame it's roughly on par the 6950
XT and 6900 XT but crucially it is over
30% more costly than what we believed
were the sensible previous generation
high-end options in the RTX 380 and 6800
XT actually it's more like 50% more
expensive when compared to the 6800 XT
still when compared to what I call the
dumb options like the RTX 380 TI 390 and
390 TI even at 1440p the 490 is
comparatively good value the 4K data
using the MSRP is even more favorable
and here the 4090 appears far better
value than the 6950 XT and 6900 XT
offering around 15% greater value still
it is 16% more costly per frame and
compared to the RTX 380 and 21% more
costly than the 6800 XT still it does
have 24 GB of vram so when compared to
the 390 we're looking at significantly
better value with a saving of 38% per
frame now looking Beyond msrps and
instead focusing on current real world
pricing the RTX 490 is a lot less
attractive using the 40 40p data we see
that it's actually slightly worse than
the 30902 in terms of value making it
the most expensive GPU on the market
today in terms of cost per frame and
overall price the 4K data though better
represents the RTX 490 but even here we
see that at $1600 it is slightly more
costly than the 6950 XT though also
slightly better than the heavily
discounted RTX 390 so I guess that's
pretty good for a stupid high-end Class
Type product let's say that said you're
looking at a 21% premium in terms of
price and performance over the RTX 380
which frankly isn't good still we're
comparing a brand new product to a
2-year-old GPU that's now selling below
MSRP so while a valid comparison for
those of you looking to buy right now
older discounted products are almost
always going to represent better value
so what to make of the gForce RTX 490
well it's obviously very fast it's
brutally fast in fact as I've said a
number of times now but I don't think
performance was ever really the issue
here I think the key concerns people
seem to have with the 490 was the price
and Power consumption now the price is
obviously understandable and it is a
real issue but the power consumption I
think it's clear now that the rumors of
just absolutely insane power consumption
were wrong that the 490 isn't absurd in
that sense using slightly less power
than the 390 TI in our testing so while
still a very hungry GPU it's nothing we
haven't seen before from Flagship
products and given the exceptionally
high performance the performance per
what you're getting with the RTX 49 is
incredibly good we also saw when to the
same frame rate in cyberpunk 2077 that
the 490 consumed almost 50% less power
than the 390 t on almost 30% less than
the 6950 XT and this then leaves the
issue of the price and that's not an
easy one to get around based on the 4K
data using msrps we s the 490 is 16%
more costly per frame than the 380 which
actually isn't that far off the margin
seen previously When comparing the 390
and 2080 and although I didn't have time
to include the 2080 data here the 390
upon release was 13 % more costly per
frame than the 2080 so that means the
490 is pretty similar in terms of value
to that of the 390 which wasn't a good
value product because the 3080 was just
133% slower on average while costing 53%
less so when looking strictly at ultra
high in GPU pricing the 490 it isn't
terrible and I guess for people with
Deep Pockets who buy these products
that's a win of course what made a great
in my eyes was the RTX 380 and although
the crypto boom did spoil it for a
moment it was pretty great so the hope
is the RTX 480 at least one of them
represents Great Value and that's
something we'll explore at a later date
my point is though until more Ada love
La gpus arrive and of course amd's rdna
A3 gpus it is hard to say just how good
dumb or bad value the RTX 490 is for
this new generation not only that but I
can sit here all day and complain about
the $1600 us asking price but It
ultimately will change nothing
accomplishes very little and won't
discourage those who plan on buying an
RTX 490 from doing so there is clearly a
market for these extreme high in gpus
and if enough people are willing to part
with $1600 us or more for an RTX 490
then this segment will continue to exist
and nothing I say will change that so
moving past the cost per frame or any
kind of value analysis to just look at
the RTX 490 for what it is a brutally
fast GPU how excited should highend Gam
is be again ignoring the price I am very
excited about the RTX 490 it's the first
time I've enjoyed a truly High refresh
rate gaming experience at 4K without
having to compromise on visuals rate
tracing is finally a Carefree option and
while dlss is still important here
enjoying games such as Dying Light 2
cyberpunk 2077 and Watchdogs Legion at
4K with ultra quality R tracing enabled
while frame rates stayed above 60 FPS
it's a special experience DS S3 is
obviously a very exciting new feature
but as I've said more investigation will
be required here before I can comment on
just how much of a selling point it is
and we'll have more information on that
shortly so in short the gaming
experience with the GeForce RTX 490
founded Edition was breathtaking and
surprisingly practical as well I was
able to run it just fine using my old
corser RM 850x 850 W power supply using
the included adapter the found Edition
model running Under full load for
extended periods of time is very quiet
no louder than a quality mid-range
graphics card and as I've said power
consumption wasn't outrageous less than
that of custom 39 etiis that I have and
again my 850 wat power supply doesn't
look as though its life's going to be
cut short now I know Nvidia made several
bold claims when announcing the new
GeForce 40 series but I really don't
care to delve into that here company
saying dumb stuff has become the norm in
fact it's pretty much always been this
way you can argue AMD doesn't
misrepresent their products nearly as
much as Nvidia maybe that's true I
really don't care to get into that
debate here they're both guilty of
stretching the truth or at the very
least focusing on Extreme outliers or
highly unrealistic test conditions and
that's kind of their job I suppose at
this point you have to get over it and
accept that that's just what they do
that said I'm all for stamping out
really anti-consumer Behavior such as
commissioning or paying for third party
benchmarks something both Invidia and
Intel do and have done quite a bit of as
for the RTX 490 there's really not much
more to say at this point in time
personally I'd never pay $1,600 us for a
graphics card because as good as it is
Gaming's just not worth that kind of
investment to me and I suppose more to
the point I can enjoy gaming almost as
much with a GPU that costs at least four
times less so I still feel we're firmly
into dumb GPU pricing territory here but
like I said how dumb depends on the
price to Performance offered by the RTX
480 models and of course amd's upcoming
rdna 3 Series so rather than rush out
and buy 49 I just wait to see what AMD
has to offer and it won't be too long
now till we get a look at amd's rdna
gpus and really from what I'm hearing
you really shouldn't have too much
trouble buying a 490 anyway should you
decide to go that way I've heard that
stock is apparently very plentiful and
with that I'm going to end this review
here very impressive stuff again but
yeah Keen to see what else we end up
getting so make sure you are subscribe
for that if you enjoyed this video you
know what to do and if you'd like to
become a harbor box Community member
then we do have float plane and patreon
you can sign up to either one of those
things that'll get you access to behind
the scenes content a monthly live stream
with Tim myself and our exclusive
Discord server along with a few other
cool perks so yeah if you're interested
check that out but if not perfectly fine
and I would like to thank you for
watching this video I'm your host Steve
and I'll see you again next time
[Music]